the jogan experience do you remember
when we first met remember we first met
the strip club in San
Diego you can I say can I say say
something but can I just say something
about it yeah I think I might be wrong
the way you're saying it maybe how so
well I don't let's let's go but so okay
I you were headlining La Hoya yes I was
a door man yes right and I think Diaz
was Diaz was there I believe so yeah I
think he was there right I knew Diaz
right so he goes hey let's go to the
strip club with Joe and I I was like I
was trying to be a host was this 95 yeah
95 96 okay right wow and I was a kid
right I was enamored by you you know
what I mean not enamored but I was like
I doubt it I wasn't even famous back
then no but still you were headliner I
was an MC right right so then we go to
the strip club right and it's deja
vu okay okay okay and I wanted to go
like I'm from San Diego I know the ropes
I know the people I didn't okay of
course I didn't that's not really what
happened no but we sat there okay and
then there were gang members there right
right and then we I don't know what the
problem was but there was a problem
between I'll tell you the problem okay
okay there's one of the gang members was
dating one of the strippers okay and
when he was over there talking to the
stripper you went over and tried to get
the stripper to give you a lap
dance and when you did that I saw the
look in his eyes and he had I'll never
forget he had long straight black hair
it's Mexican dude with tattoos on his
face in 9 only two two teardrops that's
fine okay that's only two people he
killed okay and this is 95 okay and um
you went over and I said Bobby what the
[__] are you doing what the [__] are you
doing I go did you take a look at that
guy's eyes yeah I go Bobby these are
like dangerous real people and you're
like oh shut the [__] up this nothing's
going to happen they ain't going to do
[__] I go okay I'm out of here so I said
I'm leaving you can either come with me
or not and I got up and left I saw where
this was going they were getting up
Bobby they were moving around they were
thinking about coming over to you and I
got us right out the door and you barely
got in my car you barely got my car in
time you were Dilly dallying and someone
had to yell at you and then we got you
in the car and we took off I hey Bobby
you were going to get a shot like for
real you saved my life I don't know if I
saved your life but I definitely saved
you an but but also if she's working
there she's on the clock no just hear me
out no you're if I'm at McDonald's right
and some woman technically correct I'm
technically correct technically you're
correct correct but she was over there
talking to her gang member boyfriend and
you went over asking for a laugh dance
and you you just like stormed your way
into their conversation you were going
to die can I just say something yes
please I want to say something okay at
the time I found this out later I
thought the teardrops meant he was
emotional or something I didn't know
about death okay even if he didn't have
Teardrops on his face the look in that
guy's eyes like if the the whole group
of them they were serious make
assumptions about people
okay do you have any self-preservation
instincts whatsoever what do you mean
did you have any self-preservation intin
we from the suburbs we don't we don't
know danger that way we had no homeless
we had Surfers you should be just
inherently like a a child sees a dog's
teeth and scared of them you should see
that guy growling and go okay this is
real Joe I'm 52 now I've never had
anything happen to me so I feel like my
instincts right are on the on point
you're also very
deci not to kill you smile yeah so what
what the [__] dog I go yeah yeah that's
a good move that's a good Mo that's a
good move yeah yeah but that that was
our introduction that's how we became
friends
[Laughter]
okay